let's get right into some notable
discussions from the david pakman show
subreddit you can join more than 32 000
of our viewers and listeners on the
subreddit davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t
um join the discussion and a lot of
important things being discussed there
here is a question that has been coming
up a lot and there was a very
interesting uh discussion and poll of
our audience the question is do you guys
have any sympathy for anti-vaxxers who
wind up getting sick with covid19 and
we're gonna look at such a story in a
moment
and
the the majority in our audience said
no
but i don't wish death on anybody or
no
they should have known better so a lot
of not feeling any sympathy for people
who don't get vaccinated and later get
sick
um some in the audience said i have a
little bit of sympathy but not much
and by far the least common answer among
our audience was yes i do have sympathy
for the anti-vaxxers who get sick
and i hope they all have a speedy
recovery i'm sort of in that minority
and i understand that there is a
significant level of uh
ignorance
and um uh uh disconnection from reality
in many of these people but i do
consider themselves victims and i know
the egg man will call in and say david
you're too empathetic that's not gonna
get you anywhere maybe that's the case
but um i think that i mean listen i
think it's totally normal to resent the
anti-vaxxers there is no doubt about it
they're extending this we have
widespread vaccines available here
and they're choosing not to get one and
this furthers the spread
and it increases death and it increases
hospitalization i get it so i understand
resenting
but also when i hear that someone like
for example pro-trump anti-vaxx radio
host phil valentine is now on a
ventilator which we will talk about in a
moment
i don't i don't feel good about it it
doesn't make me i don't like that
um so
that's the point of view i guess of the
audience another post from the subreddit
called clearing up the arguments over
mask wearing brings up a couple of
interesting questions and it says now
that the cdc is recommending indoor mask
wearing again even for vaccinated
americans i'm already seeing the insane
outrage and ignorance from conservatives
we saw last year i thought this would be
a good subreddit to make sense of the
issue because i feel like i'm losing my
mind so i'm just clearing this up feel
free to discuss
there's plenty of evidence to show that
the vaccinated coveted patients do not
end up in the hospital in fact they
experience very little symptoms this is
like the flu shot right i remember the
one year i didn't get the flu shot i got
the flu i was bedridden for a week i got
the flu this last year with a flu shot
had a minor headache and sniffles this
is the way to debunk any argument
stating the vaccines don't work see we
told you
then you have the mask wearing why would
i wear a mask if i'm if i'm vaccinated
well because you can still transmit it
to the unvaccinated we might have some
people say they don't care about giving
it to unvaccinated people which honestly
i find perfectly okay but that's the
reason the cdc is recommending masks
right lastly why do these conservatives
think mass squaring is about government
control i don't get it biden hasn't
taken advantage of government control at
all that's what they always said it's a
slippery slope no they're just going to
want you to wear a mask because we
haven't 100 defeated this thing right
it's insane to me how little i can
empathize with their views right now
unless i'm the crazy one which is what
i'd like you all to help me with because
to me these people must be very very
stupid and lack any critical thinking
skills how is it possible to reason with
them how you can't and so the pretzel
that you find yourself in trying to talk
to these people and saying how can i
just get them to get it why don't they
understand it
unfortunately we can both feel sympathy
and empathy for people who get sick and
resent them
and be going out of our minds because
any conversation with them is an
exercise in futility and frustration and
desperation it's all of the above and
you know there's this concept from uh
i don't know if it's i don't know if i
don't know what area of psychotherapy
it's from but it's basically being able
to hold two conflicting ideas at the
same time right you know in a
relationship it might be that you find
yourself incredibly angry at someone who
hasn't treated you right but yet you
still love them because they're family
or whatever the case may be and you've
got to kind of hold both ideas it's the
same thing here and the word empathy
keeps coming up we can both empathize
and sympathize with people who are
getting sick without being vaccinated
and be mad resentful and frustrated up
to the wazoo because of those very same
people i think it makes absolutely
perfect sense join the discussion weigh
in yourself at davidpakman.com reddit